the first two yes you've guessed it the
just stop oil morons take 56. prime
minister Richie sunac held a summit with
event organizers and National sporting
bodies today to discuss how to stop
these cretins from Wrecking our summer
of sport he told the Sun newspaper that
Johnny bestowed the cricketer had some
bright ideas for fixing this blight
here's a reminder of what bestow did
and the best so just waving to the
dressing room maybe it's his gear
well that's the way to do it and you
throw him over the sidelines like a
piece of trash which is what they are
frankly will play inevitably on chord 18
at Wimbledon was briefly suspended twice
today when just stop oil protesters
scattered orange confetti and jigsaw
puzzle pieces over the court
[Applause]
and another disruption
although the reaction of the crowd did
you detect Universal support for this
movement cheers of yes you go you go
just up Oil we're right behind you or
did you hear what I heard which is loud
Relentless booing jeering and abusive
shouts from a public sick and tired of
this
it's another PR owned goal from a
protest group who seems determined to
become the most hated in modern history
and elsewhere an annoying protest
anti-monic is demonstrated as targeted
King Charles in Edinburgh today
yeah they are with their trademark
yellow t-shirts and placards as the king
arrived at St Giles Cathedral
foreign
[Music]
how many people do you think they want
over today or anyone in the crowd going
you know what I've actually gone off the
Royals I think God joined the movement I
doubt it um well I'm joined Now by a
friend of the show where is Posner from
the Auntie monarchy group Republic uh
and also by the green Tycoon and Justin
boiled backer Dale Vince so Dale uh
Vince uh we're welcome to both of you
but Dale let me start with you Trevor
Nielsen who is a big uh supporter of uh
groups like just stop oil came out in
the Sunday Times last week and said it's
become disruption for the sake of
disruption working people trying to get
their job get to their jobs uh dropping
kids off at school or just enjoying
themselves there's now a case where pink
hair tattooed and Pierce protesters
stand in front of the cars so their kid
is late for example it's just
performative it's not accomplishing
anything I actually believe it's become
counterproductive and I just feel like
that has to be said by someone involved
in the beginnings of what it's become
this is going to require an immensely
difficult navigation of the middle and
the activist they're ostracizing the
exact people they need to engage they're
creating an excuse for people to stay on
the sidelines blocking Bridges he said
is a lot easier than Building Bridges
and that's what we need to do if we're
going to succeed I think he's right
isn't he I mean I just don't see any
upside now to what these just stop all
protesters are doing they are
deliberately wrecking ordinary peoples
in many cases hard-earned enjoyment
watching sport that they love and for
what
my turn
I think it is so look
um I think your language is
um exaggerating right there they're
wrecked sport they aren't wrecking
people's lives the climate crisis is
Wrecking people's lives as killed four
million people already and it does make
20 million people every year homeless
right I call that disruption cricket was
about three minutes today there was more
disruption at Wimbledon from the rain
than there was from the protest so I
think you're making much of it I think
they are doing a good job because they
continue to put this issue on the news
agenda but everybody hates them
again an exaggeration well someone
exaggerating listen to the crowd to the
crowd here
okay that's not everybody is it pissed
around at Wimbledon is not a single
person applauding that's the cheering at
Wimbledon right that whole crowd at
Wilmington like the whole crowd at Lords
I was there for that uh like all the
crowds all these events that they're
wrecking or trying to wreck with their
attention seeking the truth is the
British public are absolutely sick and
tired of this it's just not working
Trevor Nielsen's right it's backfiring
it's seen as performative seen as
attention seeking and it is destroying
Bridges rather than building them
the strategy is it working
now I disagree with you and with Trevor
I think performative art has a powerful
role in our society actually in shaping
how we think about things and what we
think and I think that these very brave
people are putting themselves In Harm's
Way and and creating a constant media
attention for the climate issue which we
have to have because it's doing such
great harm and it's driven by fossil
fuels and our government are intent on
drilling for more oil and gas to make
the problem worse what they're going to
do excuse me is harm people actual harm
to people their lives and their
livelihoods by drilling the North Sea
for more oil and gas they're going
against the scientific consensus and the
political consensus globally to do this
foolish thing claiming it will lower
energy bills which is a lie because they
know that they can't do that because
fossil fuels are priced by global
markets we allow them so so again like I
said to you last time I have a lot of
sympathy with a lot of the arguments I
think we should do a lot more than we're
doing as a globe although my real issue
is with countries like China and India
who are by far the worst polluters in
the world it's not actually the UK and I
don't see any of these heroic protesters
getting on a plane to Beijing or to
Moscow or to Mumbai there's a moral
cowardice about this they're targeting a
country which actually has been doing
more than almost any other to be
Progressive in this area but aside from
that
if you're going to have a movement
you've got to bring people with you I
don't know anybody literally anyone who
is watching these scenes time and again
at all these sporting events and
thinking that's going to make me join
this movement it actively puts people
off
okay how about some facts on China
because it comes up all of the time what
about China the per capita carbon
emissions of the people in China yeah
are tiny right way smaller than they are
in Britain and just last week it was
announced that China has built more
solar panels than the rest of the world
put together right which includes
Britain and they're at 50 green
electricity on their grid now and that's
where a country of over a billion people
what percentage what percentage of
pollution what percentage of the global
pollution comes from China
bear in mind is 1.1 billion people
making most of the world's stuff
including the stuff absolutely
tell me now you tell me you're the
expert
I'm telling you per capita as an
individual per capita it's a percentage
of global what's important percentage of
global pollution there are eight billion
no
you don't want to tell me eight billion
people on this planet I'm telling you I
don't know you should tell me right I'm
telling you I don't care per capita at
this time globally
they're built more solar power than the
rest of the world put together peers and
they're at 50 green on their electricity
grid I say those are amazing
achievements when you say what about
China yeah I say they they produce more
than a quarter of the world's pollution
and I don't see anyone from Greta
filmburg to you guys getting out there
to Beijing and shouting at them or
wrecking their sporting events and we
all know why let's bring in rizz is
chuckling away because you find all this
terribly amusing uh there is you
supported just up oil uh no one at
Wimbledon today supports just up or
they're just think you're a bunch of
idiots I know you weren't there today
you were shouting at the Royals up in
Scotland why do you support this kind of
protest that we're seeing at all these
sporting events
oh I'm not sure I've completely condoned
that and to be clear I'm not speaking on
behalf of Republic today I speak on
behalf of no more Royals but absolutely
we're protesting in Scotland and peers
you're gonna like you've just been going
on at these guys are just the boil about
why are you disrupting Ordinary People
and why don't you target the right thing
and we've been doing that uh shouting at
the king why do you support that method
of protesting why don't you come out and
condemn Justin Boyle like Trevor Nielsen
who was funding some of this stuff
before I suddenly realized the pennies
dropped it doesn't work
uh I'd like to talk about
coronation because it's but uh to
respond to that question uh we're in a
climate crisis it's horrifying I'm
terrified for my future and just the
foil are one of the only uh groups of
people at the moment who are doing
anything about that but as I say I'd
like to focus on the issue well I'm sure
you would I'd like to focus on what's
just happened because it's indicative of
of a summer of protests by people who
think they can convert people to their
cause even if people are inclined to do
so we're now at a point where you can
tell from the audience reactions at
these events they literally want to
garop them and what worries me is it's
gonna lead it is going to lead to bad
situations if this carries on because
people are going to just going to take
the law into their own hands
uh sorry that's
stupid sorry you don't see swearing you
want to talk about the protests
we wanted to talk about the process or
do you want to say uh that protest
shouldn't happen and we should all suck
it up and deal with it because that's
easy for you right like you've been
dealt with pretty good hand I believe in
peaceful protests but I actually care I
believe in peaceful protest I don't talk
about the peaceful protest I believe in
peaceful protests I don't believe in
Wrecking ordinary people's lives as
they're going to work is they going to
hospital as they or some cases going to
funerals I don't think that when they
play the sporting events that they maybe
save money for all year long that's fine
ruined by a bunches let's talk about it
there was a republic up at one end who
were a massive crowd far bigger than any
of the monarchists I mean the streets
are pretty much empty uh I haven't had a
chance yet to look at any of the
coverage but I think you'll see that
because uh there is pretty much nothing
going on on the Monica's end and the
Republic demo is enormous
uh and then there's no more Royals who
did a banner drop uh chanting can I
swear I just did uh the king feed the
hungry because that's what we want to
talk about right uh
they've they've done this you know what
it is for a bright young woman who's
getting a very good expensive education
you do behave like a complete
foul-mouthed idiot you don't need
yourself any favors why do you think
coming on a show like this and just
repeatedly using the f word why do you
think that makes you look any better
yeah I did apologize for that in advance
but that was what we said three times
yeah uh F the king yeah I'm happy to
censor it uh F the king
um feed the hungry that's what we were
chanting uh because that's what we
should be talking about today the first
coronation was ridiculous it was a slap
in the phrase of the British people you
asked for a question it's this do you
really think do you really think the
best way to persuade people of your
argument is to come on a show like this
laugh man technically of people who are
doing ruinous things to people's
enjoyment and then just keep swearing
all the time do you think that really
helps you do you think people watch this
and go she's really persuaded me that
girl while she was so eloquent she was
effective they don't they just think
it's again performative attention
seeking you want to get your little
YouTube moment and by the way you'll
probably get one and good for you but no
one's going to come around to your cause
that's it I can promise fair enough
um I actually don't want that YouTube
movement moment uh I don't want your
fans calling me assorted slurs on
Twitter
um and to be fair right I did say at
multiple points can we talk about the
issue can we talk about this outrageous
by the way I don't think we even
mentioned I mean everywhere there's been
a second coronation and no one showed up
um you know I could only apologize for
swearing but uh yeah I think the
Laughing was more to do with your
ridiculous coverage of it yeah well as
always always a pleasure to have you on
thank you very much thank you